this is what they want the pattern of
Demands is a constitutionally required
statement of General objectives these
are the general objectives
increase minimum compensation
significantly to address the devaluation
of writing in all areas of Television
New Media and features
no we can't do that not one we can too
that's I'm speaking now for I'm speaking
now
because I know because these are my
friends the billionaires I'm speaking
now for them because I wear the glasses
that they wear do you understand do you
have a furry Polo thing that's 3x
and it was bought in a bin yeah
I'm going to tell you what we can do and
what we cannot do
this doesn't mean I'm I'm I'm the person
who's representing the billionaires but
I'm for the writers so it's easy to get
confused here
I'm in solidarity with the the
Communists that don't want to work